morale is
high here in spite of physics being
suspended
because of a recent covid case and that
case
was in spite of a high uptake of
vaccinations
of 118 staff only three
haven't had one abby has been trying to
talk them round
personally i think it should be
mandatory because we're
where we need to protect the vulnerable
people that we look after we need to
protect ourselves
our friends our family and also reduce
the burden on the nhs so
i think it is vital that people have the
vaccine yeah mary
that's your sticker for your vaccine all
residents have been
vaccinated here now the government is
consulting on whether
all staff in england should be as a
condition
of work if you're coming into contact
with very fragile frail
people who if exposed to covert
would could likely kill them then it's
only right and it's only responsible
for us as a government to consult on
this
consider it very carefully and then if
need be obviously
legislate accordingly some staff who
didn't want the vaccine said they were
nervous about medical intervention
one believed conspiracy theories
whatever people's reasons are for not
wanting the jab
the issue here is how far an employer
can go
in making workers do something that they
don't
want to do the pandemic has already
rewritten the way many others work
unions say making the vaccine mandatory
could be a step too far
do we know that it it's a very low paid
sector deserves to be much higher paid
we know that it's a sector um whether
there are
high turnover rates and lots of
vacancies for roles
and so the potential risk of people
walking away from the sector is
is great care homes have been badly hit
by the virus for a minimum level of
protection
scientists say 80 percent of carers and
90 percent of
older residents need to be vaccinated
nearly half of homes in england haven't
achieved this
lisa dowd sky news birmingham